[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
comm presents the second annual fall
chess classic you are looking live at
the st. Louis chess club boardroom in
the tournament hall where today
questions may be answered as to who will
be the champions of groups a and B come
on in to the studio and join us hello
chess fans my name is Ben Simon and I'm
joined as always by the wonderful
international master Eric Rosen today
Eric we have two top two top players in
either section who could win their
respective groups with one round to go
that's right drea of leading group a by
one point and GU Busey and leading Group
B with two points so if he if good
boozing draws or it gets any points
today he'll be Group B champion but
we're gonna get into the games and see
see what's going on yeah first let's
take a look at the standings here in
Group A first of all so in Group A
Alexei dray of leads with one point and
he could win today it will probably go
into tomorrow a lot of key games in this
matchup we will take a look but in Group
B here is the one with more immediate
circumstances of Hanukkah boozing with a
two-point lead had he scored or should
he score anything in this round
this group is over as far as round one
goes will still play tomorrow but as we
get into the games we will realize maybe
that is not gonna be the case today
here's the tournament format really
quick we have 210 player round robins
the time control is 90 minutes 440 moves
and there's 30 minutes for the remainder
of the game after that 30-second
increment from move number one and
important to note that the players
cannot agree to a draw before
Black's xxx move to encourage fighting
chess okay here's the tournament
schedule today we're on the air at 3:30
p.m. tomorrow though everything is
different the games will begin at 11
a.m. Central time and you can watch them
at us chess champs calm now we will be
on the air with you two and a half hours
after that at 1:30 p.m. Central Time and
hopefully the key games are still in
progress when we come on the air to join
you and reminder join us all across
social media Facebook Twitter we are
broadcasting live on YouTube and twitch
as always and of course us chess champs
calm remember to hashtag fall chess
classic to join the conversation okay
here are the pairings for groupie group
a first of all our masters division
Hanson versus Brewer zone that is an
important game first of all more about
that later hammer versus Seth women a
cobia versus cooze above spirits versus
Lenderman and there's no doubt about it
our key matchup it's right to Lux a drea
of
leading group a with five out of eight
points playing ray Robson who has had
somewhat of a topsy-turvy event winning
some games losing some games now at an
even score going into the penultimate
round let's take a look at the current
position because a lot has come off the
board I do want to back up to when
things got interesting around this point
when drea played Knight to b5 putting a
lot of pressure on the c7 pawn with both
the Knights and the rook it turns out
black can't actually defend c7 given
that there are two attackers and zero
defenders so ray decided to just snag
away the the B to pawn after Knight
takes even lot of things were under
attack
all of the rooks almost all the
retaining in this position for both
sides and after Bishop takes he won the
rook takes e1 White was temporarily down
the exchange but clearly winning it back
going forward here at rook to c8 then I
take e6 all of the rooks come off the
board and after Bishop takes c1 ft6 King
off one this brings us to the current
position
where it's some a classic night versus
Bishop endgame white is probably
slightly better here just due to the
fact that there are pawns on both sides
of the board usually the bishop is
happier in these situations or it can
work more easily transfer itself to the
Kings side or Queen side if need be
however I would probably bet my money
that this game will be a draw given that
just so much has come off the board and
there are there are no passed pawns in
the position so I would expect ready to
hold on and get the half points well and
if nothing else what a draw would give
us is at least some excitement for
tomorrow because that would guarantee
that group a is not decided today
because to four point players in Group A
are playing each other and that is
Hanson and Bruges own so one player at
least guaranteed to walk out with four
and a half points one point within the
leader so some excitement there let's
take a look at the pairings in Group B
for round number eight as a robb versus
Jacobson Ashwin versus Mordy Abadi
you versus Holt Dirk versus Boros and
our key matchup yeah Oxshott Chandra
taking on the most dominant player in
Group B thus far Havana's Qaboos Ian
Hawk shot has lost the majority of his
games this tournament being tied for
last place with two out of seven going
into this round
boo boos Ian with six out of seven going
and this going into this round only
dropping in to half points I do want to
take a look at what has happened because
the game is actually over oh my goodness
and Akshay has won has taken down the
Group B leader we see Mike Hummer
they're resetting the board very
stunning results given that GU boozing
has just been on fire this whole event
but a nice win for our shots if we just
take a look at the final few moves
played in this game you see rook to c8
seems like white is invading via all
directions Queen variable based on age
six rook is now pinning
the night on he ate and white is
actually currently got the piece of his
position two after rook to c7 Bishop h7
was all said and done
given that the King really has no safe
place to go if King f7 there the Queen
g6 King f8 and Queen g8 mates and
meanwhile if Queen take h7
there would be rook taking Yates and
black is just going down hard so it
would be great to get our shots in the
studio we have not had them yet this
tournament yeah in fact we are gonna
have him in just a few moments
before we get to him let's take a look
at what these players are fighting for
in this event because well there's a few
different things but the one thing
that's universal the prize money $22,000
for group a first place walks out with
$6,000 and in Group B there's also a
very generous $14,000 prize fund or if
the champion walks away with $4,000 Erik
I understand we do have actua Chandra
ready to talk to us and he will get him
set up in the studio but let's take a
look at a game in the meantime while we
have him in here absolutely I do want to
go to the game between Christopher you
and Conrad Holtz because things are
getting really really crazy let's go
back and see what what exactly happened
in this middle game we have kind of a
classic opposite side castling situation
White Castle on the Queen side black
castle on the Kings side so we see white
is is hoping to go for a King side
attack here
Christopher played pawn to f4 pawn b5
and this is a common type of idea for
black to try and sacrifice a pawn and
open up the file rook to b8 could be
played and there would be two half open
files for black to attack with so the
plan was not taken Bishop to d3 played
bishop to b7 and now we see just
incredible move by the youngster in this
position I would encourage viewers to
pause here and try and find
sensational move for white
in one moment we are getting an
interview set up with Oxshott and we're
actually going to come back to this game
I'll leave it on the hook here but I do
want to welcome
Oxshott Chandra sorry into the studio
congratulations on an amazing win today
Thanks
I don't know if it was amazing but it
feels good to win after a while of
course take us through the game because
it seemed like you were down on time and
then all of a sudden you were just
crashing through with just an amazing
attack yeah it escalated pretty fast I
mean I had a slight edge but it was
nothing serious and then he just
collapsed pretty fast so yeah the
opening was a guy didn't really expect
him to play the grin field but I did
prepare something there so h4 was pretty
aggressive so you take C 4 is the most
principled move but C 6 is very solid as
well he probably wasn't prepared for it
and is this the line that you've played
before this h4 question of the first aha
so was this something you kind of have
kept in your back pocket for previous
games yeah I guess so I really got a
chance to use it so yeah after c6 takes
takes we've got sort of like an exchange
slob oh it's it's bishop on g7 and I put
my pawns on h4 so it's probably a bad
for me if it was on like H 3 H 2 it it
didn't comfortably better for white but
because the pawns on H 4 is just
slightly better
so yeah 1963 Castle Queen b3 yeah b6
yeah I was out of my preparation here I
probably have looked at this but I just
couldn't remember so I just started
playing natural moves route c1 there
should be seven yep it should be - and
were you spending a lot of time in the
thing because it seemed like no I played
this pretty fast castle I moved pretty
fast because those are pretty obvious
moves
yeah after 94 I started thinking because
it felt like I'm better but it's not so
easy I mean his position is very solid
and it's not easy to come up with a good
plan here so I thought Queen a3 makes
sense getting out of
the way of 95 maybe Bishop B sticks in
the future 95 ideas like I did in the
game yeah I was surprised by his next
move
age six but I guess it has some logic he
wants to play g5 in it seems a bit
strange for black to be trying to attack
on the Kings side with you're already on
e truer but maybe he thought that he
could exploit it or something
yeah I think night before I was ok g5
yeah I don't think I played it in the
best manner now I'm not sure if Bishop C
stone is the best move I was considering
other ideas too like Bishop d6 and 96
but somehow I couldn't make them quite
work we should be six maybe a six you
can play like it's nasty intermediate at
Fischer take f8 your queen gets hit yeah
and if I play 96 in this position yeah I
was calculating like G takes f 4 9 takes
B 7 Queen e7 so I can take on Eastern
and take on f4 I wasn't sure about this
end game though because the different
ones pretty weak like he goes night of 5
it seems like your night is just very
that all stop - hi and besides marooned
yeah we're get d1 like rook c8 and like
I'll have to give control to C file and
niacin that'll be Sona stranded default
ones weak so you know I'm upon up
temporarily doesn't look so good for you
so going back to what you did playing
the game Bishop to c7 yeah seemed like
things were forgetting I started mystic
but after Queen d7 95 to be 5 I think
you should play Bishop c6 here I missed
that initially
blocking the C file and hitting my night
with the temple
and yeah well I'm sure that play here
and next movie can even just grab on h4
I mean I think the computer I was just
checking it outside said it's still
slightly better for white but I still
think it was his best chance or 58 he
was moving incredibly quickly the the
time situation at some point he had over
an hour and you had lesson yeah five
minutes to seem like he was playing at
bullet speed it's quite impressive
actually
yeah root gives c8 okay I thought HD 5
is normal
yeah I'm not sure about route 68 because
gives up control the C file I mean his
quintic queen recapture was a blunder
but he takes back with the rook I'm not
sure relief I have much I mean I guess
he was worried about Queen takes a stone
but plays rook c2 and he gets a lot of
counter play mm-hmm I don't think he's
done much worse at all do you think it
may have been a mistake for him to just
be playing so quickly when things were
so complex but it's it's just probably a
style so that's true he has good results
with it as well I guess you just missed
the Queen infiltration I mean F he was
also very tempting here I couldn't
decide between the two but I wasn't sure
about 92 and it's probably still winning
somehow but it requires a bit more
calculation but what I did in the game
we should take some Queenie sound like I
don't even have to calculate just play
you know that's very intuitive you know
I mean Black is under serious pressure
after he come in I see success so Ruby
it I was surprised but I think his only
more was Bishop c6 which is not so
obvious at first time I think he was
gonna play it actually he had his hand
over the bishop then he paused and
played with b8 but yeah Bishop c6
I was calculating f3 here
Knight of 697 because 96 Queen d7 and he
gets to trade the Queen's so yeah and
this is not the type of position you
have Queen's come off the board for sure
so unite see sunroom Beatrix g'wan I
thought I'm winning at least a pawn here
for example Queen d7 wait just a sec
oh wait we are just no no this is
correct ninety six ninety okay the queen
is overworked and she exploit this pin
it's a nice tactic and then the N games
obviously completely winning I mean I'm
a pawn up and I've controlled on the
open file so I'm sure but that was still
probably yeah chance exactly but I can
understand why you wouldn't want to play
that yeah Ruby I don't I think it just
tremendously
full momentum and in your favor and I
have six ninety six and yeah just pure
defensive fertilizer I would give it
just desperation I mean Bishop eight is
exactly the move you want to make but
it's very true I think I was gonna play
make a fort here and just play five next
and just and if pawn take your F takes
just happy to open that file
yeah DF file is just devastating very
nice so look to the eight and yes my I
got worried that I missed something that
I was like haha it's completely yeah
we'll just admire the end of the game
seemed like you
we're completely crashing through yeah
sure I mean the good thing is that the
forest comes to worst I can also play
Bishop a6 and protect the night so he's
never really getting the piece back
that's true yeah but obviously I would
prefer to finish it off in a meeting
attempt of course so you you just gave
the the tournament leader his first loss
of of the event I know you've had a
rough event thus far does it still feel
good to kind of have a wind towards end
and maybe finish finish strong
yeah I definitely needs a very strong
player like you said he was undefeated
until now so it feels good to do in this
game do you feel like there's some like
psychological benefits that there's no
there's no real pressure on you going
into this game all the pressures on him
to try and clinch at least clinch a draw
it's a secure first place
that'll be the other way around though
because you know he's in good form use
confidence so he he's playing really
well you know I'm playing too
I've been playing terribly and all the
pressures on me to sort of get a
respectable finish so
okay I don't think this game meant any
less to to me than it did to him fair
enough
and one more question because you live
in st. Louis I know you play a lot of
these these events yeah what's next for
you after this tournament I'm probably
gonna play this my scalp another st.
Louis tournament that starts next week
yeah the 23rd so that's a strong
tournament as well well best of luck in
that and good luck tomorrow too
we're going to take a quick commercial
break and we'll be back with more
coverage from the 2018 fall chess
classic
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advised from
the best and even challenged them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight
coverage of the 2018 fall chess classic
Ben Simon here along with international
master Eric Rosen and during the break
we've had this this game in Group B it's
just crazy Chris U is looking really
good against Conrad Holt and this is big
news for him that's right I do want to
jump to the decisive moment in this game
Christopher unleashed this amazing move
kind of coming out of nowhere
bishop take aged seven now this is a
relatively thematic sacrifice in such
positions where it is also side castling
and the Queen can come in very soon to
h5 if we see how this plays out it just
looked completely crushing for light
after king Teague aged seven the root
canal also infiltrate via d7 which was
played and after Queen c8 rook hd1 white
isn't even going for the media Queen h5
check the rooks are just so dominant on
the D file and it was very difficult for
black to challenge white at all in this
position Queen h5 is always looming
bishop or King to g8 was played and
after rook 1 to d3 we see this looming
rook lift and after the shift to c6 rook
h3 and there we have a handshake
hopefully we'll get Christopher in the
studio so they are just finished very
very quickly I'll shine seems a bit
surprised they're walking in front of
the camera right now I don't know if you
mentioned the the norm story here yet I
don't believe I have
even though Christopher you is was in
last place going into this round with
two out of seven points if he wins his
last two rounds he just won this round
so if he wins tomorrow he will clinch
his final I am norm and I believe that
would make him the youngest
international master in in the country
so a lot on the line right and you know
you it's not something that we've been
thinking about along the way since he's
the bottom seed and you know he's up
against a really really tough field but
not only does he have
that potential 2-norm tomorrow but he's
playing gabbu Xion tomorrow that's a
huge matchup gooo Busey and going down
heart today
yes seems like momentum is now in
Christopher's favor but of course okay
Christopher will be playing for a win
tomorrow I know he has the black pieces
but whenever there's a norm on the line
and you're in a must-win situation
you're gonna play for when you're not
going to take that that quick draw
absolutely where did you complete your
look at the how that game ended so we
should jump to that just real quick just
to have some closure and then hopefully
we'll have Christopher here soon to give
us some more in-depth analysis but we
see the the rook did lift over to h3
just a beautiful game by white given
that white has so so far sacrificed at
Bishop on h7 now the rook on d7 now what
could take the Queen but there is no
need for that Queen h5 is just pretty
much unstoppable mates Queen h8 is
looming
Conrad tried one desperate attempt
Bishop to e3 check King b1 and then
Queen d1 check it's almost checkmates
but not quite for the other players out
there you should realise what to do here
for whites this is just a computer
spike check right Queen take Stephen
it's a spike yeah just Queen take t1
which is actually the only legal move so
white would have to play this after rook
ft8 the Queen returns
h5 and Conrad threw in the towel here
given ok there is one more slight check
let's finish this game up we have Chris
coming into the studio here so we'll
have him in just a few miles sound good
yeah Queen take d1 would would just be
all but over any and there's ripped e8
but then Queen take d8 so we will wait
for Christopher but in the meantime
let's check out another game that is
still underway I do want to take a
glance at the version of Cobian game
because he is up upon and if we look at
the current position Bishop h3 is played
keeping lights rook at bay the rook
cannot activate itself via e3 and there
would would be a VAT great mates with
rook c1 so it's a Cobian to move here
and it is a question how to potentially
make progress with extra pawn because
for the time being black's rook is more
active there's ideas of rook to c3 and
there's no immediate counter play for
white this this King f8 move was very
useful for lack not allowing any
potential back ranked main ideas so a
Cobian seems to be taking his time in
this position I could imagine something
like Bishop to d5 perhaps defending b3
in advance though this could run into a
move like rook to d8 and then it's
somewhat of annoying skewer if if rook
e5 is played then black can start
kicking around the white rook and we
might see could see something like rook
aged 5 and then both bishops are hanging
but after he moved like Bishop to g4
black should not be having any problems
in this position so a Cobian if he wins
this game he will keep his chances alive
to to potentially tie for first going
into tomorrow
so we will to keep an eye on this but I
do want to switch back to the
Christopher u game because we do have
Christopher in the studio
congratulations on a very quick and very
ecstatic win today so were you were you
surprised that you were able to take
down such a strong player so quickly or
did it just feel natural playing this
nice attack a little bit although I did
have a game against him a couple months
ago that I did take him down quickly
because of mostly because of opening
preparation mm-hmm he also he's a pretty
predictable player so I can prepare some
surprising stuff and today is it go yeah
I actually forgot that you did play him
in the California state championship
right just back in September
no I actually paid him an enormous
enormous in our area
I see and were you white in that game as
well yeah and so how did that game
compared to this game was it a similar
opening or a little different because he
played Bishop before today he prayed I'd
have six but I expected that
yeah always nice to have have some
expectations of what the opponent will
play and I know the the French defense
is a pretty expected opening from from
Conrad so how far prepared were you in
this game maybe twelve or thirteen moves
but I remembered ideas farther mm-hmm up
to like move six sixteen I still use
some day idea yeah I know this is uh
this is a very thematic position
especially with opposite side castling a
lot of ideas are pretty classic for
whites especially going for these
king-sized sacrifices so if we reach
this position after Queen to c7 seemed
like the play flowed very nicely for you
with 95 and then pawn f4 at what point
did you feel like he made kind of a
crucial mistake maybe allowing Bishop
takes h7 or maybe be fide may have not
been necessary maybe ASIC that died and
then I can be one I think was my
preparation okay so this is a position
that you've studied before and I study
the bishop takes at age seven ninety in
another variation but when taking on c1
there was the squares Bishop to b5
laughter yeah with the king on c1
sometimes there is there's potential
counterplay for black the King on b1 I
know Bishop takes h7 is winning haha
according to the NGOs interesting okay
so after Bishop e7 how long did it take
you to to calculate all the variations
and play Bishop take h7 here twenty
minutes or so
oh wow so that's a long time but of
course if if you think it's winning then
makes sense to go for all right yeah I
already knew that
so Bishop takes eight seven I already
knew that this was idea or when the star
birth d7 and PGA and I actually worked
HD one was my preparation in another
line here I kind of stopped with my King
on b1 when we're taking on c1 the
condition is unclear is a little more
unclear yeah that's interesting that
you're able to use preparation from very
similar position but then then it's all
about kind of identifying the
differences and maybe the nuance ISM the
variation did you see any any sort of
defense for him in the Fineman I thought
he should play queen bee age instead of
Queen C and what would the difference be
if I premiere HD one now I'm not
threatening Queen age five in nine takes
f7 because a queen takes a floor so
something like king b1 is possible maybe
king b1 instead of work HD one no rock
HD one is good so after a HP one there's
something like bishop CA
Brook one D 3 work one D 3 now
could you still in official take t7
you're just okay King I'd say I favor
cage-free g6 this is a night no Knight
takes if Knight takes c6 Bishop takes
these seventeen dancing queen age five
King G says your knight defends that
four which is nice King g7 Queen h6 king
of six nineties there's even Queen g5
it's not for stole maybe brac has a
better defense like Bishop seeing is not
floors this room seems like boxers
always under major pressure it's on it's
unclear maybe black has a defense but
from a human standpoint it's quite
difficult to defend this position
that's very true of course maybe if you
turn out the computer will find some
miracle defense but I just know it
didn't with a king on v1 fair enough
yeah and that's we go back to what
happened to game it seemed like there
was this little hope after okay after
rook h t1 in this variation seem like
all the moves until the end just came
very easily yeah
h3
queen h5 - should be three daddies these
fight Chuck stand scary Bishop III first
but instead of Queen takes Keystone Oh
when your Bishop III here you still
think that's winning
that's like Queen takes III Bishop 67
Queen D free f96 there's ideas in shaded
95 okay rookie a rookie cheats
let's say you know this is a war
yeah rookie j7 95
these variations could get bad here I
mean I don't have to pay 96 maybe you
could go for like Queens III and Queen
h4 yeah queen c5 is counter bread with
Queen do you want ideas you only realize
this resource later like at first I
didn't see was pretending I think here
just be three no oldest squeegee ones so
maybe there's this move on I moved 20
Bishop III was was his last chance
yeah Bishop takes a ideas efficient see
if we can find something okay yeah I
said yeah I found something I remember
uh cruising queen is five Queen D 323
she is from the f5 is the best move
Bishop a chess rook takes Atrix take
squeegee freaking each other cases wait
slow down
okay so so instead of f5 if he faced
Bishop h6 her case h6g thx Queen g3 King
AJ nine eight seven seven York takes f7
birthdays I've Queensgate there's 25
that's nice go bad so I five would be
the f5 after Queen d3x after Queen's at
e3
it's very close for lights
sure this is a position you'll you'll go
back home and check with the engines
yeah III if we go back even further just
wish that could be should be okay so
that's let's say a cake on you three
with a queen and we said she should take
g7
maybe not so easy at least let's say I
try Frank h4 f6 I got night g6 that's
tricky
yeah the king was finding some some
shelter let's I did go back there's a
after Bishop takes d7 after now these at
least there's something like rook g3 if
g6 now I think look f5
oh wow just busting open the whole
position and if you take out five 90s
Jesus 66 pawn to g6 and white is down at
rook in at Bishop Queen I have some
initiative Queen h6 yeah this doesn't
work g7 King yes sometimes when you
sacrifice too much you'll run out of
ammunition I don't want to spend too
much energy calculating these variations
I know you have a big game tomorrow if
we just see how the game wrapped up he
played Bishop e3 perhaps a bit later
which just went completely in your favor
Queen D wanted to surprise you at all or
of course you just take it and queen
returns to h5 so this puts you at three
points out of eight going into the last
round do have to bring up that if you
win tomorrow's game you do get your your
final international master norm and
you're playing against the tournament
leader
Havana's caboose Ian who lost today what
are your thoughts about tomorrow are you
excited are you nervous it's hard to say
maybe more nervous or I mean I know he
pays for your four different opening so
he's not necessarily the easiest
opponent to prepare against but yeah I
think it's gonna be a interesting game
that's very true
and you you have the black pieces will
you be playing for a win or are you just
trying to play normal chess I guess a
normal chess find the best moves and see
what happens that's uh that's a very
mature approach so I will let you go
rest and prepare and best of luck
tomorrow so we're gonna go back with our
coverage of the game still underway I do
want to look at the a Cobian game
because it seems like he's managed to
unravel his pieces with getting his
Bishop and his rook centralized and
holding on to the extra pawn if we go
back to where we last left after King f8
let's go back to yea this position after
Bishop h3 this is a bit of a question
what white had to do to make progress
Bishop g2 was played Bishop goes back to
thee seven should be for Bishop h3 now
we see a Kobe ins idea with pawn to d5
perhaps just keeping the pawn defendant
this is a passed pawn in the center
after a bishop t7 back now laconian
plays rook to e3 I'm a little bit
confused here why blacks not go for the
media Brooks III given that seems very
logical to activate the rook so we're
gonna have to keep an eye on this game
because a cobia and still has chances to
to fight for some of the top places but
I do want to welcome back then Simon to
the studio any updates and any of the
other games we have no results but I
think that a game we should look at is
Daryl spirits versus Alexander Linderman
as Lenderman fights to stay in first
place contention it's may not be looking
too good for him
Darla's looks really aggressive as white
over in group a I'm trying to find that
game I'm struggling a little
here we go okay so yeah Darwin swears I
know has not been having the best event
currently what he's he tied for last
place
I think he's got two points mm-hmm yeah
so he yeah he's in clear last right now
and Lenderman has had some rough games
recently just falling to drea yesterday
losing in just 23 moves with the white
pieces so perhaps both player is trying
to maybe finish strong after not the
most desirable results if we take a look
at the current position we see just a
nice sort of domination from lights I I
do admire White's position I mean white
hazard the ship hair it seems like black
is very much restricted the bishops are
piercing through box position this night
is is completely pinned on d7 and
there's this very nice outpost on b5
controlling more squares in black story
territory and really restricting
especially this dark square bishop dark
square bishop would love to somehow
trade itself off via d6 or via c7 but
white is controlling both of these
squares with the bishop and the knight
so the move that was played by lunderman
was night to e Yates which just looks
like a very sad move but it is perhaps
fighting for control over these dark
squares and perhaps idea is to
eventually play a move like Knight d6 or
Bishop d6 because when you're solo solo
in space and there's still a lot of
minor pieces on the board it does make
sense to try and trade and free yourself
up so one more move has been played rook
to e1 pressuring along the e-file and I
like this move by daro because it puts a
question what to do with this Bishop I
just mentioned that lunderman would
probably like to play a move like Bishop
d6 but this runs into some tactics on
the removal of the guard tactics given
the knight on he 8 is defending the
bishop white could first remove the
knight and then capture on g6 and go up
a couple of minor pieces for roof this
would be a very beneficial material
balance for for the white side so rook
e1 putting the question looks like
another
has been played instead of moving the
bishop forward Lenderman played Bishop
to f8 moving backward but trying to
remain solid and it seems like the next
move our blacks next move is Knight to
d6 trying to facilitate some trades and
now it's a question of whether White's
can sufficiently apply enough pressure
to keep the advantage and it keeps
initiative in this position all right
very interesting game here so far
between spirits and Lenderman elsewhere
in let's see here yeah
Group B Dennis Boras black versus
Stevens urk let's take a look at that
one
wow this is actually a very crazy
position I'm not sure immediately sure
who's better but I do like blacks elif
just with the two bishops versus the two
knights especially the the battery along
the like squares for black this Queen
Bishop battery always eyeing this this
pawn in g2 we might expect to move from
lights soon to play something like f3
just to try and undermine the battery
from black but it was box move here and
Boros did decide to go for some trades
and captured on e4 perhaps liquidating
the position and after Queen take e4
Bishop to g4 lots of things are coming
off the board if we count the pawns
Black is up upon but there is some
somewhat damaged structure given that
these are two isolated double pawns in
the center of the board
now speaking of pawns Locke did decide
to grab the undefended pawn on f2 and
seems like some trades are about to take
place but white does have some issues on
the back rank given that okay there's a
media thread of rook take to you on
checkmates if rook take T aids rook
takes you eight there would still be the
threat of rook to d1 and it seems like
y-you this a little bit slow here
to regain the pollen deficits given that
okay Brooke d1 Scylla threats I move
like g3 could be played but black is
temporarily up in two pawns if they were
to reach this position and it seems like
black is probably the one playing for a
win and we know that Denish had a nice
one yesterday so if he can win yet
another game I'll be uh nice finished in
the tournament for him yes do you think
that I mean when will white actually be
able to capture those two be pawns I
mean they're they're so vulnerable
looking but well we should go back to
the current position sure that is a good
question because it seems like after
they should take f2 white is now
thinking in this position whether or not
to trade rooks I mean white will
probably win one or both of these pawns
at some points but as far as black
strategy goes it's a matter of slowing
light down and keeping the initiative we
could see a move like rook f1 this is
another candidate move just to attack
the bishop on f2 now I'm realizing there
might be some kind of fancy tricks for
black in the position but I could leave
the bishop on defendant because keep in
mind they would still be rook to d1
possibilities if the bishop were to be
captured and there would be a nice move
here for black rook to d4 just a
pressuring the the knight on c4 the rook
on e4 white would have no time to take
on e5 and if rook take d4 then Bishop
can just recaptured and black would be
holding on to the the e pawn for perhaps
much longer because if work to e1 there
the Eroica fades always eyeing the back
rank and also planning a rook to f5 so
this did not occur in the game instead
of rook to f1 zerk played this move rook
to d1
which actually looks like a nice remove
this attacks the b4 pawn and now white
is threatening to take it with check and
the e pawn is still hanging so it looks
like white will be winning back perhaps
both pawns relatively soon and then
it'll be a question who will be the the
player playing for a win if material
does equalize okay Eric we've had a lot
of fun so far in this show but I this
this middle pumpkin is rotten man and
it's really starting to stink so there
is some mold yeah it's really beyond
there's no return for this it might be
easier to carve like we could even carve
it with like a butter knife at this
point yeah well I was thinking more
along the lines of just putting it
outside so give us to the rats oh hey
look we have some replacements though
it's okay well speaking of replacements
if we hey I don't think we need any
virtual pumpkin no no no meaning one and
I did this is a pumpkin bought a few
days ago I think that's much more of a
minimalist approach given that we don't
need all these there's a lot more that
we'll have to save for for future shows
but okay I think we're good just using
this guy for the time he's fresh I get
us to tomorrow yes yeah see here we go
alright one of the important games in
Group A Eric Hansen versus was our obras
own two of the leaders four points
apiece and this is a very important game
let's see if either one of these players
can emerge from this round in a really
good position yeah let's take a look
I mean first thing we should note is
Eric is on move and he's running low on
time he has under four minutes left
bruised own has left left the table for
the time being now if we count material
Eric is down upon Bach has an additional
pawn on the queenside but these are
double pause perhaps reminiscent of the
game that we just saw and there's very
beautiful knights on
d four-block hitting the double pawns it
seems like why does the one pushing for
some some sort of positional advantage
here despite being down upon but it is a
question what to do next because for the
time being black seems to have
everything under control we could
imagine some of like Queen JK 5 this is
a one pawn which is not defended in the
position we see Erik hand on his head it
was about to make a move but seems a
little bit hesitant now he's just frozen
in that pose Queen take a five looks to
be played so material is now balanced
now there is one glaring weakness in
White's position that's this efore
square which I'm not actually sure if
black can exploit right away this would
be a beautiful outpost for the Black
Knights the only issue is that if 94 is
played instantly and then d5 would hang
and Erik would be quite happy so that
was not played trying to make out what
was played at position looks like rook
e8 was played and then very quickly
Hanson
dropped his Knights back to C to
defending the rook on e3
still seems like a dogfight
I mean it's imbalanced enough due to the
structure also due to the fact that
white is very extended on the Kings side
with these pawns not really protecting
the white king so I always have to be
careful when Queens are still on the
board and your king is running a law and
shelter that there's no immediate attack
that the opponent's could try and
unleash now I'm imagining something like
rook take III they take e3 and then
something like Queens 6 where the
Knights attacked the pawn on d5 defended
and if then I move anywhere then the
Queen could come in either to e 2 or a 1
so could it be an interesting line for
black and it is a forcing line too I'm
sure
Bru's own is pondering this position and
may be thinking how why
could best us save himself might have to
play a move like night to g2 but this
would look quite ugly as the Queen could
still infiltrates there would be ideas
of 94 it seems like white White's queen
is a bit out of play in a lot of these
lines where if that can start
coordinating the Queen and his own
Knights then there could potentially be
some some more worries for the light
King sometimes in chess that the Queen
plus night combination is one of the
most deadly mating combinations between
any two pieces you know another game
where the pieces are coordinating quite
well they are the pieces of settlement
over it's still here in Group A hammer
versus sefferman
hammers King looks a little unsafe right
now very very shaky on g1 even though
okay there is some pawn shelter black is
as making use of the darks for control
with the rook very nicely planted on g3
and yeah just speaking of piece
coordination we can see that the knight
is very much ready to come in via g5 in
fact that was played Knight to g5 now
with the winning threat of Knight h3
taking advantage of the pain along the G
file this would work the White Queen and
the king so it looks like hammer quickly
played Queen e2 and it's still a
question how does cetera and
breakthrough in this position I mean he
has literally all of his pieces on the
Kings side look they look very very
menacing but for the time being it's
still a question it's 9 H 3 would be a
check but then the White King could
start running and I don't see anything
immediate for a black in this position
so sometimes it's a question how to how
to make progress when it seems like your
pieces are are fully optimized
I mean is there away cuz I really don't
see one either that seems like the queen
is is actually a bit stuck right H for
it would be very nice for black if the
the Queen and the pun could just switch
places if the Queen was eight on each
five the pond was on each four black
would really like to get in this pawn
break with h3 just to destabilize the
base of White's pawn chain but this
isn't so easy to achieve and the Queen
would have to perhaps untangle itself
because the rook and the night are are
blocking any sort of escape squares
maybe we can imagine that move like
Queen and to h3
again taking advantage of this pin and
also tying down the White Queen to
defending G - given that the Queen moves
away from the offending G - it we make
for black and this would allow the
pollen to advance one square further and
then maybe we'll see the Queen escape
via this diagonal maybe Queen e6 and
then we can see pawn h3 so this is
really the first attractive idea that
comes to mind for for the black side and
I mean for the time being white seems
just completely stuck in this Bishop on
a3 so depressing there's no immediate
counter play against the black King I
mean there's always shelter the black
King on the square like h7 so I don't
think Rick d8 would be too threatening
so if I had to put my money on it I
would predict Queen h3 in in this
position and for anyone watching online
this is sometimes an exercise that I
like to encourage students to do is when
you you put yourself in the position of
a strong player and just try and predict
their next move without any help of the
engine without any sort of any sort of
external help you just try and predict
what they do and then see if if you can
play like them or if if their ideas
completely outperform your ideas
so it's uh sometimes instructive
exercise watching situations like this
and by the way you can do that at us
chess champs calm you'll notice by
default the chess 24 module on that
website has the evaluation meter turned
on you can turn that off in the settings
so it's still a great place to watch the
games and no spoilers so to speak it's
very true
let's take a look at Sergey Asura vs.
Brandon Jacobson over in Group B Brandon
Jacobsen a player that were quite
familiar with this point one of the two
youngest in the field Azeroth we still
don't know too much about him what do
you make of this position so far that's
good point I think actually I want to go
back I want to actually go back to the
very beginning of this game this is a
game that caught my eye earlier as being
a very very theoretical variation of the
Sicilian and going forward here they
went into what we call the sveshnikov
variation this is a very old line named
after a player of Kenney special akov
who actually played a couple years ago
in Lafayette this is a incredibly
theoretical line lots of lots of books
have been written about this specific
position after pawn to e5 and it seemed
like Jacobson was very well prepared in
the opening I know this before the
broadcast began he was just blitzing out
his moves and by moved like 20 to 25 he
had more time than he started with do
due to the increments and I want to zoom
forward because all of this has been
played before and I want to get to the
point around here Queen g3 Queen h6 and
then Queen III Queen h4 and then g3 I
get to this position
earlier when I was looking at this I was
looking at my chest org where they have
the opening explorer where you can see
basically any specific position and how
many times it's been played before this
position has been played a handful of
times before
and it's been played by none other than
surrogate Azhar of has had this position
back ten years ago in 2008 and the game
ended in a draw I believe he was playing
spaz off and that game another
grandmaster and in that game sir gaze
opponent played queen to h3 in this game
Jacobsen played queen g4 and I wouldn't
be surprised if Jacobsen had perhaps
seen that game that Azara has played ten
years ago and perhaps used it in in
preparing for this game and and maybe
prepared the specific position so just
based on the opening preparation I I
like the way that Jacobson has handled
himself so far going forward here
several more moves have been played and
let's zoom quickly to the current
position because even though Jacobsen
move quickly in the opening he is
running law in time now his clock is
falling below one minute and after
Bishop to d5 it's his move
I mean just an immediate evaluation I
would have to prefer white here even
with black having the bishop hair seems
like white has simply better structure I
mean just two pylons 1:1 Paul Island on
the Queen side one plot Island on the
King side no real pawn weaknesses to
speak of and meanwhile blacks structure
is more of an archipelago just pawns
scattered all over the place there are
three isolated pawns all of which are
potentially weak and this night is very
well placed it's an outpost blockading
spawn and at five fixing it on a light
square so seems like lazarev has some
nice positional pole to potentially
grind down the youngster Brandon
Jacobson and Jacobson's rook on a one it
looks like it's in a good spot but it's
not really in position to do anything
right yeah what to do with this rook it
needs some I feel like I'd be able to
pick off some pawns but there's yeah I
mean it it looks pretty but I think this
is what we call a decoration
it doesn't really contribute much value
anything really much like this pumpkin
so there I I would think the rook is
just gonna stay there for for a bit of
time I did not mean to insult the
pumpkin by the way but it's okay let's
move on
give it some sympathy taps Bishop d7 was
played and now his are I was thinking
looks like update the board here cuz
it's still a question okay how does
white perhaps target blacks weaknesses
because okay though the pawn and i-5 is
well defended pawn on d6 is also well
defended so it will take some work for
whites to try many progress in this
position one move that sticks out is 93
just to attack the rook you want to
attack the bishop on e5 that's not what
was played though as RF chose perhaps a
very slow subtle pawn a3 just giving
giving black a choice what to do in this
position doesn't seem like the most most
threatening move but it does keep
everything very solid now okay all of
the Queen side pawns are very well
defended Jacobsen quickly played rook to
see aids putting the ball back in as our
escorts
I like rook c8 nice nice control over
this open file and maybe we'll see this
these pawns on the Queen side even
though they're a minority there's two on
three from Vox perspective maybe black
would like to go for some minority
attack and go for a pawn before it's
always interesting when it's a two on
three imbalance on one side of the board
sometimes the two pawns are better at
creating weaknesses within the structure
of three pawns and I move like before it
could allow this rook to enter via c1
and then maybe the ricany one wouldn't
be so much of a decoration given that if
the rooks are doubled up there'd be some
some counter play against the white king
all right very nice i it's been a while
since we've looked at our key matchup in
group a Aleksey period versus ray wraps
and let's check back in on that game I
don't think much has changed but it is a
very important matchup but in this round
yeah we still see the Bishop versus
Knights imbalance if we go back a few
moves let's see how play is developing I
seem like Draya vis looking to push on
the side where he has a majority
three-on-two should know it and I mean
the goal for white in a position like
this is to somehow create a passed pawn
and create a situation where okay the
past pawn could be dangerous and then
maybe use it as a decoy to focus on
another side of the board
so after pawn f3 Knight to e7 just seems
like black is just very solid and white
could try and create the past bond with
a move like pawn h5 which looks like
Draya play the move believe pawn h5 was
played don't know if you can make out
there what was played kini 4 was played
perhaps anticipating 95 as it would come
attacking at 4 but any time white does
go for this h5 break it could leave
white with a weakness black could
capture it after pawn takes back on h5
white would then have a couple of
isolated pawns and the knight would be
in in decent position to defend on the
kingside cross with and move like Knight
f5 so it seems like Draya that is taking
his time here not going for any
immediate pawn push but just trying to
be move around and wait for her when the
opportunity does provide the present
itself we might also see white go for a
move like f4 f4 and maybe when the time
is right either go for f5 or h5 we had
Dre up in the studio yesterday and he
mentioned he's in the process of writing
a book on end games so I'm wondering if
if going through that process of writing
a book like that could maybe help him in
a situation like this maybe so I have a
question though is it an option for
Griff to take the king over to the Queen
side and harass the a and B pawns that's
a very legitimate question I mean King
King d4 and king c5 was not an idea that
I mentioned but it's very real because
in these pawns if if the b5 pond has
attacked the knight is not currently in
good shape to defend it and we do see
with Reyes last move Knight to c6
he is restricting King to d4 and even if
I wanted to maybe bring the King to c5
there's no clear way to do so you see a
very strange move by dre of your Bishop
to a-1 what is this it's putting the
bishop in the corner maybe just a
waiting waiting maybe putting the
question what to do for black because
enough now if the knight moves then the
King could potentially it infiltrates
and meanwhile if and I can't move then
black has to make some other commitments
if the King moves towards the center
maybe then we'll see pawn h5 well Robson
played King g8 is that a waiting move as
well King g8 looks like a waiting move
help me update the board here bishop a1
King g8 maybe some confusing moves here
but looks like both players are waiting
it seems like ray-ray seems pretty
comfortable after especially after
seeing mission a1 I mean he played
King's Yates fairly quickly perhaps
realizing the situation that it's hard
for white to actually make progress
given black setup I do want to mention
here that black has some very nice
coordination between the Knights and the
pawns especially the the knight
controlling these dark squares and the
pawns controlling the light squares
there's actually no way for the light
King to effectively enter blacks
territory essentially that all of these
booth squares are acting as a wall
restricting the light King
and there's no clear path to get to to
the C Phi square which is something that
light would dream of meanwhile if King
DeForest played maybe trying to enter a
via g5 looks like black could just keep
waiting with the move like king of seven
and just supposing the question to how
light is continuing here so I would be
surprised if this game ends in a draw
perhaps somewhat soon right yeah that
looks likely and elsewhere in Group A it
appears it well I want to see if you
think that Eric Hanson is as
uncomfortable as I think he is right now
in his game against Brazil and we should
note this is a key matchup for the
standings of Brazil in this game and J
of draws there's a chance for prefer for
zone to catch up in the final round
yeah this is looking very uncomfortable
for the the chest bra backing up just a
few moves we see that yeah why does
probably regretting overextending on the
Kings side and black is just entering
the territory winning upon an a4 after
king to h2 now rook to c4 seems like
White's position is just falling apart
and the time situation can't be helping
light either given that Eric is below a
minute on the clock
and okay box still over three minutes
for the time being they do have four
move for more moves left to make move 40
let me see an aggressive move by white
pawn g5 but this seems like sort of a
desperate attempt given that okay this
is also weakening White's King side
further and now the knight could perhaps
jump in to h5 and now ff4 pawn is going
to be a target instead H take g5 was
played
I would expect light to recapture with
fthe five and then we still might see
night age five
and the South Foursquare just looks very
very juicy for a black the night
connector f4 or the rugged enter f4 yeah
seems like white especially with these
pieces kind of lined up on the second
drink not not the most energetic
placement and the Knights on c2 is as
perhaps a liability for white as the
Queen and the rook are are tied down to
defending it
so looks like bird zone is thinking here
perhaps considering nine h5 may be
considering something else the other
candidate move to look at is ninety four
way more direct in this case white or
black excuse me would be attacking the
Queen also pressuring the pawn on g5 and
we might see a situation where the Queen
will be overworked given that the queen
is currently somewhat tied down to both
the knight mc2 and the pawn in g5 of
course the Queen would have to save
itself but presume did not go for this
instead razón played perhaps a slower
and maneuvering move but very logical
moves Knight to d7 it's interesting I
was only looking at the the Ford Knight
moves brew zone shows a backward Knight
move but with the intention of moving
forward and now we can see the knight
has a beautiful central up Oh square e
five where it would be very stable
supported by the d6 pawn and from E 5
Blackwood that had access to f3 and the
knight will also be helping cover some
squares on the Kings side so I do like
this move I black and it seems like
seems like Black has a lot of winning
chances going forward from this position
another game that has just seen actually
a night moving backward is over in Group
B between Ashwin and more idea body
White has just brought his knight back
to d1
I suppose repositioning it have we
looked at this game yet Eric I don't
believe because the last one that we
have not seen I'm just trying to refresh
myself I was looking at this game before
the broadcast but it's game Lee perhaps
overlooked just because it was a bit
more positional very calm in nature and
getting to the point that you're talking
about here after rook take b4 and rook
to a2 black is actually down two points
but has a lot of initiative with these
rooks on the half-open V file targeting
the pawn on b2 and the only way for
white to defend the pawn here is this so
much of pressing move Knight to d1 but
this does kind of keep everything held
together and we should note this is move
40 so both players have gained the extra
half-hour on the clock
one more move has been played rook to a
for attempting to still try and win back
the pawn we can imagine that if white
takes back on a for the bishop can
recapture both players standing up there
okay Ashwin LC sitting back down always
nice when you reach move for that you
can take that coffee break or the
bathroom break or the stack break I know
the players have a lot of snacks to
choose from in the kitchen area oh yeah
so awesome and maybe you're realizing
the situation after okay for is played I
think he'll have to capture and then
there will be a situation where the
Knights attacked and the knight is tied
down to defending b2 so it looks like
black will be guaranteed to win back at
least one pawn and if Knight moves let's
say to e3 and rook take beat
kingi one and okay white is still
probably playing for a win despite the
the sub-optimal pollen structure in a
situation like this when the pawns are
are in close proximity the knight is
actually performing better than the
bishop just because if the bishop can't
really utilize its long-range
capabilities as plays is mainly focused
in the center and we can imagine that
the night okay it's like it's looking to
go to a square like c4 maybe eventually
five also there's ideas for white to
play g4 and if the pawns get traded
then white would be left with a passed
pawn on the G file so seems like Ashwin
is the one playing for a win here and
this game is important for the standings
right both players are at four points
and you know in Group B going into today
kibou ZN could have clinched it that has
not happened so these guys are still in
it
look boozy and still the far and away
the favored to win this whole thing
tomorrow but this is a very important
game either of these could find these
players could find themselves in a very
good position tomorrow right and good
booze ian would only need a draw
tomorrow against Christopher you to
clinch X but with this dynamic of
Christopher and they've just entered the
game or maybe just shaking his hands oh
so they drew and it looks to be the case
does that mean kibou Xion has clinched
it even though he lost today because the
only other player that could have caught
caboose Ian was Conrad Holtz who had
four points and he went down pretty hard
against against Christopher you I think
you might be right yeah
- ask aboot caboose e'en with this with
this draw was the groupie champion his
groupie champion yeah
it's incredible he lost today but well
there we go I mean books well we'll have
to talk to him at least one more time
tomorrow but but look his game tomorrow
is still super important against Chris
you Chris you could be the story book of
the story book finish of Group B if
things go his way he says like a boozy
and is not the easiest player to prepare
for and well that much was obvious
taboos Ian came in the highest rated
players number one seed and now he's
gonna leave with four thousand dollars
in his pocket so that's amazing amazing
turn this yeah I know it's always tough
he stumbled towards the finish line but
really got to be happy with this play
taking down a number of very strong
players in this group oh for sure for
sure thank you to Isaac for letting me
know that was it I really had just
written the clinching off of my mind but
it was still a possibility okay so while
Group B is determined there's still a
lot more action going on there is
another result actually in Group A we
saw the tale of the trapped king in the
corner with hammer and cerumen well that
game has been drawn hammer had set her
men on the ropes as far as his King in
the corner and they just repeated
because there was no way to break
through blacks wall there as you can see
I'm actually very surprised given IIIi
thought black had a very nice advantage
but maybe he wasn't able to to find the
right breakthrough if we see what
happens
9 H 3 was played and then he moves a
rook back to g6 interesting idea that
didn't really consider this does leave
the knight undefended on h3 but if white
were to take it we can imagine that
Queen takes on h3 King e1 queen h1 and
then the rook is bound to come in
to g2 or g1 depending where light moves
and black will be winning the Queen
for example Kim D - Richie - so the
night could not be taken on h3 rather a
white plate pon d5 and after Queen g3
rook c8 king aged 7 root T 5 and this is
the beginning of where we're gonna see
the repetition white is threatening upon
on H 5 black plate King to h6 and then
like Dave's rook to the 8th threatening
rook h8 and I guess so Thurmond saw
nothing better than to just go back to
h7 after rook d5 King age 6 the player
is just repeated moves and agreed to a
draw not surprising for me because I
really thought doc had some very nice
pressure in the position but I guess
wasn't quite enough to to break through
indeed I am looking right now and back
at daro spirits versus Alexander
Lindemann and Group A this is this is
one of the most confusing games to
glance at initially but it looks like
daro is still very comfortable yeah we
saw earlier with daro just having a very
nice domination in the position looks
like the players have passed move for
either I move for t1 right now if we go
back to where we last left we saw this
Bishop f8 move very passive but holding
things together rook to d1 was played
perhaps trying to maybe focus on
doubling up on the e-file connecting the
rooks to later have some more central
focus rook d8 was played and now Bishop
to see - I like this maneuver Bishop c2
getting ready to form this battery along
the b1 h7 diagonal it's always nice when
you can have your queen leading the
battery and that's what we see white is
planning in this position if Queen d3 is
played there will be Lully mating
threats against h7 square so Knight to
d6 is played and now upon each horse
seems like daro launching a
side attack after pollen g6 pani h 5y
was trying to perhaps destabilize this
this pawn shelter that black has in
place this provokes Lenderman to advance
forward with pawn g5 and white ignores
the attack on the bishop and goes for
queens in d3 threatening the very simple
made in one looked like black only had
one defense in this position Knight f6
and now the bishop enters a position
Bishop to c7 very aggressive move
targeting the rook on d8 pressuring the
knight on e6 the bishop we should
mention is well supported by this Knight
nice outpost Knights on b5 so rook e8
was played and now the bishop goes back
to e5 really admire the the peace
harmony the peace coordination by white
in this position seems like the the two
bishops are just so effective in staring
down at the black inside especially
given that black is is overextended with
these pawns on h6 and g5 going for just
a couple more moves Knight to d7 9b d7
King g2 and rook to e6 looks like one
more move has to play Bishop to g3 and
for the time being white is not actually
crashing through black has the key
squares on the King side defended I
would still prefer white in this
position but I would imagine that it
could be somewhat of of still a long
fights I do want to note that after
Bishop to g3 is played white might be
having some ideas of night see sudden
the reason why white I don't think
complain I see seven right away is
because
1985 would remove the guard of the
Knights and also attacking the Queen
then the knight would be left undefended
on c7 so Bishop g3 does get the bishop
to safety
and now nicely Sutton's of threats and
it's a question how does black deal with
this because
seems like if rook take e1 then light is
just happy to take over the e-file and
would like to show one line if rook
taking one rook taking one and rook to
Yeats this would be a tragic blunder for
black given that now the night is over
works on f6 defending just too many
things at once defending the rook and
defending each side of the square
why could simply take on Yeats and then
deliver the mate on age 7 so I like the
simple move Bishop to g3 keeping the
fresher having some threats lunderman
still managing his time perhaps a bit
better than his opponents but but yeah
well we'll have to see what happens I do
still like Weiss chances in this
position all right very well let's
glance back as we get to the end of our
broadcast portion of the show well we do
have we have to stay on until we know
that Group A will not be clinched today
so that's true that's going to come down
right the fight between draya's and
raphson and they're still battling and
that's yeah it looks looks pretty drawn
here I mean so I think there was a
capture yeah pong capture on f5 yeah
because the last time we saw they were
just kind of being very patient making
some rating lose maybe just trying to
reach move 40 we see okay Bishop b2 king
f7 so rate was probably just happy with
a draw but drea is this one pushing he
does playoffs board turns down the
repetition ray just keeps waiting very
patient can g8 and now pawn on five
finally a pawn break we do see some
trades you take out five do you take out
five and now we see ray is thinking in
this position
he has a time added there they're on
move 41 so he's already actually taken
ten minutes here to to ponder his next
move I mean the easy choice just seems
like taking on i-5 and after King take
i-5 I would just be inclined to put the
King on each seven and ask how light is
is making progress in this position
maybe ray is just making sure
perhaps calculating some Lions where
White's king could then potentially walk
in to the Queen side maybe there's still
some annoying Pole there are situations
in chests where a bishop and a rook pawn
would be drawn however in this case if
if white is somehow able to win the
knight and trade off all of the pawns on
the Queen side this Bishop and HP pawn
combination would be winning because the
queening square is a dark square so I'm
trying to imagine what ray is deciding
between in this position maybe he's
thinking about King f7 just a simple
move to defend the pawn in g6 and then
we could potentially see a very similar
similar line if if pontiac g6 King take
g6 and then King d5 it's also very
possible
it's a bit awkward robot because the
night's is getting kicked around a
little bit it's restricted by the bishop
on b2 pollen III is well placed and if
the knight has to move backwards like
Knight to e7 then white can start
picking up some pollens and then maybe
it's not so easy given that if I move
like before is played then there's a
floor and if I can hold onto the a pawn
and win both of box Queen site pawns
then there's an additional problem on
the King side this could be hard to
defend well wouldn't it be just be
winning for Wyatt
so this position yeah um I wouldn't say
it's completely winning III would
actually think that there should somehow
be away for black to still draw for
example and move like King to h5 cuz it
still takes a lot of time for life to
win both of these pawns and then start
cleaning the a pawn and if I move like
King b5 is played I think the knight
could somehow hop in and slow slow down
White's operation for example and move
like Knight d5 and if King take a 5
there would even be a move like Knight
to c3 and all black would need to do is
sacrifice a knight for the 8 o'clock and
then end up winning age pawn and white
would be out of pawns for example if
King take before night take a 4 game
take a 4 this is just a draw so I think
raised should have everything under
control with precise play but I'm sure
Ray is having flashbacks he had a game
earlier this tournament against Lazaro
bruised own which we actually didn't get
to cover on the broadcast because it
just went so long it was I think a game
that lasted over 5 and 1/2 hours and it
was a game that Ray was I think over
pushing it was a situation with night
versus Bishop he had the Knights he was
pushing for a win ended up over pushing
and lost some sort of similar endgame
where there was some kind of
race so I'm sure he doesn't want to
perhaps let another another game and
sort of the similar endgame situation
slip like that one did so he's okay he's
a professional player he's taking his
time
just perhaps deciding what option is the
most clear and I'm sure he's he's very
deep in calculation you can see it in
his posture they're just leaning over
the board and when he feels confident
I'm sure he's gonna make his move while
we're waiting for those moves to be made
I would like to talk about some big
upcoming events here at the st. Louis
chess club and abroad you know we have
just the best commentary teams in the
world as far as this Royal game goes so
this Fall Classic is one of a series and
the next one coming up is the Winter
Classic it's 210 player round robins
same format everything is the same just
different players you're gonna see some
familiar names you're gonna see some
names you've never seen before that
begins November 5 on us chess champs
calm and actually it will be we will
have Jessie cry and here for the
analysis of of that big event that
should be a lot of fun after the Winter
Classic we have a Norma bent called the
st. Louis Invitational 210 player round
robins as are these tournaments $15,000
prize fund plus the possibility of norms
we will have a grandmaster norm section
and we will have an international master
norm section that begins November 16 at
US chess champs calm and Eric actually
you were talking before about your
experience as a gatekeeper in an
international master norma vent well
yeah I've played a few of these before
and I've I've been on kind of both sides
of the aisle i-i've been an
international master in an IM norma
vents where I'm sort of the target the
target is on my head but I've also been
the one that trying to strive to get the
Nortons and there's a lot of these on
the line that for these events because
especially for the younger players if
they can perform well and get their
gettin or more get their titles it just
leads to a lot more opportunities in
international events and that tournament
is at us chess jams calm we'll see who
the stars of tomorrow in the chess world
are at the st. Louis Invitational and
then abroad in London it's the World
Chess Championship but right here in st.
Louis we've got you covered on
abbreviated commentary every day that
there is a game in that match starting
November 9 with Yasser Jen and Maurice
you can find out more at st. Louis chess
club org as we approach the World Chess
Championship now they will be talking
about more than just the world match
championship they will also have the
world women's Chess Championship with
today in chess that's the name of the
program as juin Jun defends her title in
a 64 player knockout event and of course
the people in the USA will be cheering
on our own Irina crush and sabina for
two former women's US champions and then
finally we close out the year our last
big big broadcast it's the 2018 grand
chess Tour Finals at the London chess
classic this will be a combination of
classical rapid and blitz games it's a
miniature knockout for player knockout
between Fabiano Cara Juana and Hikaru
Nakamura they'll meet in a match in the
first round and on the other side of the
bracket will be Levon Aronian and mvl
and in the winners of those two matches
will clash for the Tour Championship I
mean if the World Chess Championship the
match championship is not your thing
some people think it's antiquated this
is your World Championship you know like
that's gonna be a really big event in
London a huge month in London and very
excited to bring the action here from
st. Louis do you have a pick for grand
chess to our champion
I think Fabiano Carolina can do both the
World Championship and the London event
that that would be incredibly impressive
I know if that's likely but well of
course it's not likely to win both I
mean that's a good parlay I have to pick
Nakamura I think he is he's by far the
best in that field in blitz and rapid
and I think the universal rating system
has him still at number two yeah hey
Karan ask some more actually so the
universal rating system which rates
games across all time controls going all
the way down from the from five-minute
blitz to classical and from the radience
systems inception in the summer of 2016
Magnus Carlsen number one Hikaru
Nakamura number two now everything else
is switched but those two have been very
consistent so when you incorporate
quicker chess hey Cara Nakamura world
number two a universal rating system
I think Cara wanna in the URS is he's in
the top ten I think he might be number
six right now fair enough I know he's
not at the same elite level in blitz as
Carlsen or naka but still of course
incredible in classical chess right if
you want to know more about the
universal rating system by the way it's
not a it's not it does a low has no
bearing on it it's not an average of
ratings it's its own rating system you
should check out more information at
universal rating calm and if you have a
feed a rating search your name you might
have a universal rating you didn't know
about okay so we are getting down to the
nitty-gritty here in Hanson versus burrs
own which is now we're definitely one of
the games to watch in group a we're
really just keeping an eye on these
Group A games mostly as we close out
round eight absolutely and seems like
Hanson's position is getting worse and
worse and worse when we last left we saw
this very nice kind of patient 97 move
heading to g5
and as it plays out the night lands on
e5 now we should note that the rook is
being left undefended or just attacked
by the knight in this position but if
light were to capture on a c4 that black
would have just a very simple fork
Knight to f3 losing the Queen so 95 did
come with tempo forces white to defend
this f3 Square somehow rook to f2 was
played and then rook to d4 just keeping
initiative I really like the Courtney's
coordination by Bru's own in this
position having this nice battery along
the fourth-ranked combining the Queen
rook and now targeting the White Queen
on d2 also taking control over this g3
square we might imagine someday a knight
Knight or a rook landing on d3 just to
further increase the pressure so Queen
c2 was played and now queens of e4
interesting move might be some tactics
associated with this move imagining that
black might be props daydreaming of
Knight f3 and if rook take f3 there
would be ripped to d2 so the Queen is a
bit more useful on on b4 not only
controlling d2 but also pressuring v2 so
it just seems like white is really tied
down here it seems like a very difficult
position not to allow any sort of tackle
possibilities from from the black pieces
now Hanson did play a move here King to
g2 crops improving the king and this is
actually a common sort of defensive idea
in chess might be weird to think about
but whenever the points Knight is on a
dark sphere sometimes it's better to
have your king on the light square so
whenever the knight moves Knight won't
be attacking any light square so there's
no immediate checks by the Black Knights
and for the time being white does have
this f3 square under control but the
position just seems so weak for whites I
mean all the pawns just scattered all
over the place black having such nice
peace harmony
looks like brus own
play the move there wrote down on the
score sheets and then went back to his
classic thinking pose I'm being told
rook t3 was played it just seems like
yet another just pressurizing move this
time trying to exploit the third-ranked
and it's based on posture Hanson looks
somewhat to feed it was leaning back
perhaps realizing his doom night on III
is attacked and when the rook moves away
off the fourth-ranked it opens up the
Queen to come into e4 so we can imagine
Queenie for very very soon to come and
if Knight g4 is played my g4 just might
take g4 and was just completely falling
apart so the media question is how does
quite deal with the simple attack
against t3 and there we have it just
Hansen resigns nice victory from
bruising with the block pieces he played
the Berlin in this game which is usually
known to be similar but a Josh opening
but perhaps Hansen over pushed we saw
the King side pawns just made a bit too
far of a journey down on on the King
side and Hansen just looking very
defeated there
and quite significant to our dinner time
so what that means is that bird zone is
at five points out of eight and even if
dre of wins it still be just a point
difference so this field will not be
decided today and it will be decided
tomorrow and remember tomorrow playoffs
if necessary
there will be no dual winners here there
will be no shared title there is only
going to be one winner of the Fall
Classic Group A so who can still win
razón tray of and maybe a cobia well I
think it's okay so as of right now dre
of brews own I guess the Kobe needs to
win his game today to be in that group I
think actually what about Hanson Hanson
still well Hanson just lost yeah yeah
but so it might take some time for the
chest 24 standings to to update right
yeah well we'll see what happens I think
yeah we'd have to look at the last round
here okay so here are the standings so
far for a group a we see drea and
bruised own at the top now keep in mind
the three of the games have not finished
we'll all we know basically is that this
field will not be wrapped up today
what about Cuza ball right you're yeah
that's that's true and you have kept up
four and a half I mean you've got to be
even if it's far-fetched you know you've
got to add the point to perspective
players whose games was not finished
that's very true I mean we're expecting
drave to draw so right that would put
him at five and a half and then
in bruges own the Cobian manages to win
I think they would be the two most
likely players to to catch up yeah this
could be a really exciting day actually
to know that we have especially in Group
B to with this matchup between
Christopher you yes yeah I mean here's
group B's standings and we know that -
Oh Scott Busey and has clinched the the
first-place prize he will leave with
$4,000 but the game tomorrow between he
and Christopher you this is it's a you
know in Japan they used to have these
mixed martial arts matches where they
have the 500 pound guy versus the
lightweight and it was just like a
monster movie that's kind of what I
think about it here you have the top
seed versus the bottom seed you have but
not only the top seed the champion is he
has the white pieces but if black wins
if Chris you wins then you have the
Cinderella norm story we might have to
bring back our tiny pumpkin to compute
another fact absolutely
well I think that will do it for today
as we get really pumped up for tomorrow
and whoa a look at all those pumpkins
they're there right that's digital if
they're still there
yeah virtual and real life yeah you know
if these pumpkins aren't careful they'll
have their jobs taken by the digital
ones don't want that to happen
it's 2018
progress okay so let's move on this show
was produced by the world's greatest
production B team
Tammy Hyde was the streamer Isaac Krantz
is your graphics and audio man and our
technical director is Danny and Machuca
tomorrow remember everything starts
early the games begin at 11 a.m. Central
time and you can watch them immediately
as they start at us chess champs calm
our broadcasts we'll be on the air two
and a half hours after the round begins
at 1:30 p.m. Central Time so we look
forward to seeing all of you for our
last day of play it's gonna be a good
one at the fall chess classic for
international master Eric Rosen my name
is Ben Simon and until tomorrow we say
so long from the Show Me State
[Music]
you